After a reason, cheeks want you to recommend an increase in protein, one gram per ideal body weight in cones today.
Should I decrease fat and or carbohydrates with this change in protein?
Well, you are going to be increasing calories. So if you're if you're if you're gaining too much weight, then that's is an issue and you do want to decrease carbohydrates.
But I don't think anybody in my patient base has that issue. It's on the purpose of decreasing carbohydrates would be to decrease your glucose levels and decrease the fuel supply that a cancer might have.
So, no, if you're at normal body weight or a healthy body weight or if you're under body weight, I wouldn't change anything.
As far as your fat or carbohydrate consumption goes, if your glucose is high and if you're eating too many carbohydrates, that's a different story.
If you're under body weight, then you really can't decrease carbohydrates at all. So I would just try to increase that protein with no breaking those changes. So there's a lot of if's that answer, but depends on where your body weight is, where you're coming into this, what your body rate is.
Does the source of protein plant for animal matter? Yes or no. There's there's nothing wrong with getting as much protein as you kids through plant sources. It's just our is a person able to get it up protein through non animal sources. It's it would be difficult.
Honestly, is it necessary? Is it better to only get play a protein? I don't think so. No. There's benefits to animal protein. There's benefits for your blood cells. There's what benefits are platenate count to get some animal protein in. It's just a matter of having that balance and having good quality animal protein.
Eating grass fed beef. It's so much better, so much more nutrient dense and has good fats, good omega three's in it versus grain fed animals. So try to get grass fed beef as best you can.
I know bone broth is not recommended due to the glutamate content are both collagen and gelatin. Okay. And do they qualify as a good source of protein? Or would you recommend your protein powder instead? Well, I don't recommend.
Yes, I really recommend any protein powder because any protein powder you're going to get is only going to be 20 grams of protein. And then there's a lot of filling up point on in that. Whereas if we eat a piece of chicken, you're probably getting, you know, 40 to 50 grams of protein with just as much filling up going on. So, I don't, you know, and I just think that might be a better.
They're big for the bucket. If you can't know if you're using a protein powder.
Well, I'd recommend the protein powder that we have because it's low in glutamine.
But back to the question about collagen and gelatin is collagen and gelatin. Okay.
The answer is yes, but you have to be careful with it. Collagen can have glutamated it. I don't know the content turns on the type of collagen that you're using. The collagen does have other possible issues with autoimmune issues. It's not that uncommon.
Yeah. So you might want to test it. So I mean, do you feel better or worse when you're taking collagen. So try to, you know, ask that question with collagen. It's not that there is a way to ask it's not that a comment for you develop anybody's collagen tissue.
We see that with autoimmune patients.
I mean, it's not super common, but it is a possibility. So do watch and see if you have any reaction and flim increase inflammation to collagen gelatin to.
So if if if you needed to know these things. Collagen is tested on the side wrecks array five and gelatin is tested on the side wrecks 10.
Those are just possibilities to just be careful of that.
Don't try to look if you're taking those things. Make sure you don't if you're increasing inflammation after you take them.